poor decisions but going back to the
church though pearl right like i said my
old anecdotal story that yeah i've heard
yeah um that whole equally yolk thing
like
women when when it comes to 70 the
church being female and
there are all the men and basically all
the men in the church are taken the
women are going to have to go outside of
the church to find a man and then when
they find a man outside of the church
the pastor says oh
he's not equally old get rid of him so
the church is perpetually keeping women
single it depends on the church and this
is my point it's not going to church is
not to come and find a man going to
church is to strengthen your
relationship with god who is a man
people yes he's a man he's whatever you
want you are going to find amanda you
will find a man but my point is if you
go to church without the intentions of
i'm going here specifically to look for
a man
you will end up finding the correct man
if you strengthen your relationship with
god if you understand your faith more
you will end up going out and you will
meet a man he may not be equally yoked
at the time but you're like you know you
were saying about like a woman that's
supportive a woman that's encouraging
xyz if you're looking for a man of faith
you will find a man that may want that
faith and he will eventually become just
as faithful as you are church is not
foreign then why are there then why are
there so many single childless women in
the church right there there's there's
nothing to heal no but i'm saying i'm
saying i'm saying okay okay but i'm
saying that you're the results are not
there if what you're saying was true
then there would be results to show for
it but there in every church i go to
even even in england it is three women
for every one men there is a surplus of
single childless women and so like what
you're saying isn't correct because if
it was correct there would be results to
show it yeah i don't know i go to a
church and every every month there's at
least two people being married
okay so how many are in the congregation
they're in the congregation what
percentage of women would you say is in
your church
it's probably the same percentage you're
saying right
there like at that church some of them
some of them met at the church some of
them met outside the church and came to
the church
some of them
yeah some of them met at the church or
some of them were introduced through the
church if that makes sense i'm saying
that's that's exception not the rule so
that that happens when i'm starting to
realize yeah you've been on this podcast
i'm clearly um
no but it's not because you said even in
your church it's three women to every
one guys that means at least two are
single that means the majority of women
even in your church are single
yes but the point is the rate of
marriage
is quite high in the church people are
in serious relationships but that's not
that's not quite high if two out of the
three girls are saying i don't know the
the full percentage but what i see
is that when you're going to church and
at some point all of those men are going
to be married yeah off and they're still
going to be 70 of women left in the
church other men coming to the church
but my whole point is church is not to
go and look for man
so if you take that out of the equation
you may find the correct man i i
understand so if you take a church at
the equation you may find the correct
man no i'm saying if you take
go into church to look for a man out of
the equation you will find the correct
man church is about your faith in sounds
like manifestation i i i understand i
understand what you're saying that
you shouldn't go to church to um to look
for a man
but with with what pearl is saying there
comes a point
in
women's life they realize
i
i need a certain type of man because i'm
going to get to a point where my
eggs ain't egging no more and i'm
getting old and i know that
a good man is in church so let me go
find god in a church and yes you
shouldn't i don't think you should do
that because it's like you're going
there with the wrong intentions but that
is the mindset of some women is that
they do go there to find somebody so
that they don't end up alone when you go
there as your
self who's now found god
what obligation does that man in church
who may be a quote-unquote good man have
towards you and your madness
like you're coming to him
with all of this baggage like oh i found
god now but really and truly you don't
understand how men think men aren't
thinking oh she's found god now men are
looking at your baggage saying
don't really want to get involved with
that like it doesn't matter church or
not it could be mosque i don't care
church mosque synagogue it doesn't
matter where you go
that's that's the i mean you know god
might heal but but the men don't forget
yeah and that's the lie that's the lie
that that like oh my gosh i have a whole
bit on how church markets being a hoe i
swear to god i i said that yeah that's
all right
because this is what they do they tell
girls you can do whatever in your 20s
you can get ran through and then all you
got to do is apologize mean it and then
there's a husband waiting for you at the
end
and then and then on top of that then
then they give those girls a platform to
go talk to younger girls and say hey i
was so broken
i was so broken and then i and then i
found god later and now look at me and
i'm so happy i waited the second time
around and i got married so this is a
mating strategy that only benefits women
and doesn't benefit man because what
does the second guy get he gets a ran
through wife
who
maybe had one or two baby daddies that
now now he has to wait for like then
this is what happens is the church
leaves women single because they they
tell girls to do this
that's a terrible plan the church keeps
women perpetually single like i don't
think people understand like the church
is not a place for you to go and find a
man it will i said if it's not the
pastor keeping you single then it's the
actual actions of the people within the
church keeping you single because the
judgment that happens a lot of the time
in church when a woman gets with a guy
who's not in church right and they start
saying oh is he in the church no he's
not oh so he's he's of the world or he
hasn't or or you have to bring him to
the church yeah what the like and what
what leader guy that's a leader that is
alpha that has the traits of a leader is
going to want to follow his woman to
church especially with the way churches
are today because even these mating
strategies they only benefit women
and they see the church for the women
you're not going to church for each
other you're going to church for god if
you invite god into your relationship it
will help to heal your relationship and
that's what like this whole thing of
like forgetting about a past year you
cannot forget about the past but it
depends on your behavior moving forward
and if your behavior let's let's exclude
sierra because we're not talking about
sierra here but if you if your behavior
moving forward is of a
faith in god manner
then god rules in your relationship and
you become
whole
do you know what that sounds like i want
to hear from you okay do that sounds
like as a man yeah god rules in whose
relationship
it's my relationship then if you've got
that mindset
you'll have a problem in your
relationship no but that's the but
that's the point you like women a lot of
women don't understand how men view god
and how women view god because the
reason why women gravitate towards god
is because he's a powerful man
whether it be conscious or subconscious
you put you gravitate towards god
because it's actually a powerful man and
women are attracted to powerful male
figures a man is not sexually attracted
to a powerful male figure it's just not
like he doesn't see him like that
no but i'm right but what i'm trying to
say is the attraction for men for women
to be attracted to powerful men is
different than the attraction of a man
being attracted to a powerful man when
you are constantly
talking about
god
and your relationship with god have you
have you not heard women say i don't
need a man i've got jesus jesus is my
boyfriend jesus have you not heard women
say that
right
because women view
god differently you never heard a man
say i don't need a woman i've got jesus
and i want to hear from the guys if a
girl if a girl has been ran through
do you do you think if she finds god at
a later date is she is she equally
valuable to you
no no yeah like you'll never find a guy
that's like
and i've talked to so many men on my
podcast about this they don't this is
why men leave the church they don't get
whipped this [ __ ] because it's taking
all the accountability off of women
because the the choice the because the
truth is if you make those decisions in
your 20s you are less valuable you are
not as valuable as you were before
two men two men that less men want to
date you like because the men decide and
they're the deciders in the sexual
marketplace they they're in charge of
marriage they're in charge of commitment
but isn't your 20 supposed to be your
like
that's
that's what they say
but
i wish i wouldn't have been told that
like yeah live it up in your 20s because
now that
i'm where i'm at now it's like what i
did in my 20 a man doesn't doesn't seem
deemed that as
valuable in his eyes so if i wanted to
go for a high value man a six figure man
and i told him like yeah
this is my body account he'd be like no
and i'm like wait i know i'm a good girl
i promise like he's still gonna be like
nah cause
they say that
every
one person that you have slept with is
in 19 for a man so if you calculate that
up if you have hold up
but the church says oh you can just like
in no offense but like heal this away
and it's it's just it like you have to
understand how this sounds demand it
sounds like [ __ ] it doesn't sound
like really
sounds like this sounds like i made poor
decisions and i'm trying to make it go
away later no no no no i feel i honestly
feel like if you had a man in this room
that was a good
man of god
and grew up in a christian household i
did he was here you did you're gone okay
cool
i just feel like it would be completely
different
and at the end of the day i feel like
when you talk about healing
you have to experience it for yourself
to know that the healing exists until
you really go to church to seek god you
will not understand
because i'm a young man that grew up in
a christian household and i would say
i'm a christian myself
i've seen
girls in the church that
we were friends i didn't know them
outside or nothing like that
in church a faithful woman of god
preaching a word speaking in tongues
like
praying like big like
ex exemplary figures speak to them
outside see them outside
different
yeah you you go you go you go to you go
to uni with them different you hear
stories about them differently you know
it's saturday night they were willing
yeah sunday morning they're presented
let let me finish let me finish
years later
coming back
on a whole different tip
like oh
i'm not worthy did she find garden she
found
she found god and got married and then
and then you see the friends
when on the days where
on the days where they get ready for the
marriage thing
friends are crying
of joy going
you did it
you did it we we all watched we all
watched you the mandom watched you and
you found a brother and you did it
and you so you so no one can tell me
what paul's saying right now ain't real
because i've watched it happen
unfortunately there are brothers out
there that don't know the game well and
and here's the thing like when i was
talking about him so he married a whole
basically when i was talking about man
having standards like you shamed him
because you were saying that a good
christian man wouldn't think like this
but but in my in my experience the good
christian men they they do think like
this because why would they pick the
older girl with a high body count when
they could just go get the pretty virgin
22 year old they could but for whatever
reason that's why i'm saying when god is
within the relationship and he's able to
heal things it makes him become possibly
understanding of the woman i'm not
saying this every man there are
anomalies as we've established yeah
should you get ready
one thing i will try and leave you on
this for me
women
look at a man's future
which is exactly what you're saying
we're gonna look and heal to the future
men are different men look at a woman's
past because your past is going to
embarrass me in some way shape or form
and i need to expect that
i need to ensure paternity biologically
so i'm looking at a woman's past to see
if she can be within my future whereas
you're looking at my future
to see if i'm the right man that can
guide you in the right place you need to
be i don't know i mean i'm also looking
into your into your future but also into
your past because say for example i
don't know say i've met a man who
he could i don't know you could have had
a kid somewhere i need to know that
that's not possible okay i need to get
there
if i've had a kid what
what as in like if you've had a kid
somewhere and you've abandoned the kid
i'm not going to want to be with you all
right so what about if i tell you i've
had a kid if you've had a kid and you
take care of your kid and you do what
you got to do then cool
if you if you're if you're a man of god
you're faithful you're understanding you
provide you support you do what god has
called you to do
then what's wrong with that that's got
nothing to do with my past then
everything that after the the kid thing
is all about my future but your past as
well it plays into it all right my key
issue i can ignore the past if you have
if you do the right things in the future
yeah about the past was based on the
fact that i hadn't i hadn't told you
something um
but my caveat is you may tell me
something and that is a deal breaker but
this is the thing everyone needs to look
into everyone's past because
if you have a past that's wild and you
haven't tried to sort it out it's going
to creep up in the future so like you
might be
let's say
a predator and you're like oh no i'm
good i'm good i'm good then you get with
someone then later on this person seems
like yo why are you always looking at
this kid like what's wrong with you okay
all right girls exactly no no no she
like you know i'm saying like she's
right when you say look into someone's
past that's why you shouldn't wife up a
girl that's been ran through like that's
that's that's exactly she she just
explained it to a t that's why you don't
do it
okay so but then if both girls have been
run through
then
then there's nothing so does that mean
that the girls that have been run
through don't deserve happiness at some
point of their lives it's not about
deserving it's not deserving what did
they earn it's like what it's it's like
what what do the men want and are they
what the men want so your philosophy is
basically women can't change so because
they can't change
you can't turn her home to a housewife
meaning she's not going to change her
past so because she can't change her
past meaning she's never going to be
good in the future so basically just
left her there and that's it no i'm
telling you what men want and what men
say
i'm not i'm just telling you what it is
i'm telling you this is how men view it
and men don't want to wife up hoes
and so
and i'm you know there's things you can
do to increase your market value like
you you lose weight right you like
there's things you can do to like to up
your value to a guy
and it doesn't mean it's over for every
hoe but in general it's over for a lot
of them that's why you see 50 of women
over 30 being single and childless
and it's
it just proves like the whole statement
of this is a man's world so in reality
if we don't if we don't oblige to what
you ask or say well you better fall in
london
what the hell would they fall in line
like if
it works both ways like if
i can't provide for you if i'm not being
the strong man you need me to be you're
not going to select me as a mate
you're not going to give me access to
sex like this works both ways this isn't
a one-sided argument no no i'm just
saying like
there are conversations of if she's a
hoe then
like yeah she's if she's she there's
consequences to being a hoe yeah but
it's not like she don't know that yeah
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that if
women were told like hey this is how men
view it if you got
five to
i'll say 12 5 to 12
bodies at a certain age you are deemed
as less valuable i think less women
would be in that bracket
but we're told and especially in the
church they say you can just apologize
later and you'll still get the same
husband you would have got at 22 and
that's just not true i think that they
are misunderstood you have to work for
it
it's not that you can just
like forget your partners
what what do they have to do they have
to go to bible study and get back
together
a lot of people what are they going to
do a lot of people think is is just that
oh i can just
pray it away
and i cannot
do the work that i need to do yeah
they're so this is something that i've
learned
growing up they just said oh pray pray
pray pray pray and i don't acknowledge
what i need to do for myself because the
scripture says faith without works is
that we have to do our part as well to
heal ourselves yes god will step in
where he needs to step in but if we
don't do our part we're going to be
broken and in the church there's going
to be a broken person and a broken
person coming together because they
think oh we're in the church we're fine
we're going to be able to live it up i
yes i have a past but i'm okay i'm in
the church now i can do it and they
never dealt with what was back there
that's going to always come so a whole
is always going to be a hoe even if they
are in the church no matter if they're
there faithfully every single sunday if
they do not deal with what they have
done in the past they're going to be a
hole when they marry the man they're
going to be a hoe at the end of their
life